[Music]
jurassic world dominion isn't jurassic
world three it's jurassic park six
here's everything you need to know about
the new dinosaurs and old friends you'll
see in this super-sized super sequel
steven spielberg's jaws is often
credited as the birth of the summer
blockbuster but his adaptation of
michael crichton's most famous novel was
an equally important benchmark in
filmmaking released in 1993 jurassic
park was truly game-changing cgi was
still considered a novelty at the time
but spielberg and his team proved beyond
any doubt that it was more than a
passing fad spielberg's friend and
colleague george lucas said after seeing
the first test shots of the dinosaurs in
jurassic park it was like one of those
moments in history like the invention of
the light bulb or the first telephone
call a major gap had been crossed and
things were never going to be the same
visual effects improved exponentially as
the years passed even if the quality of
jurassic park movies did not two subpar
sequels followed leaving the franchise
on the brink of extinction it wasn't
until 2015 14 years after the
particularly lackluster jurassic park 3
that we returned to the dino-infested
islands off the coast of costa rica
while jurassic world didn't quite
capture the magic of spielberg's
original critics agreed that it was the
best entry since jurassic park the 2018
follow-up jurassic world fallen kingdom
was far more divisive but it still made
over a billion dollars at the global box
office making another sequel inevitable
here's everything we know so far about
the third jurassic world revealed in
february 2020 to be titled jurassic
world dominion
a third film became a certainty when
jurassic world fallen kingdom made over
a billion dollars but a jurassic world
trilogy was actually the plan all along
speaking at the toronto international
film festival back in 2016 jurassic
world fallen kingdom helmer j.a biona
confirmed that colin trevaro director of
jurassic world and co-writer of fallen
kingdom had a three-movie arc in mind
from the beginning biona told lrm online
the whole jurassic world is a trilogy
that colin trevaro has envisioned it's
very interesting where he's leading the
story universal had so much confidence
in its resurgent franchise that it
announced a date for the third jurassic
world film before jurassic world fallen
kingdom was even out four months before
fallen kingdom premiered the hollywood
reporter confirmed that universal had
set a release date of june 11 2021 for
the movie the fact that universal sees
jurassic world dominion as a summer
event doesn't come as much of a surprise
but a summer 2021 release date was
thrown into jeopardy in march 2020 when
production on jurassic world dominion
ceased amid the coronavirus outbreak the
blockbuster was being filmed at pinewood
studios near london the most affected
city in the uk pinewood remains
operational but the jurassic world
dominion cast and crew were ordered to
abandon ship the good news is that
filming resumed in july 2020 the bad
news is that the movie didn't make its
june 11 2021 release date instead it's
set to hit theaters on june 10th 2022
jurassic world fans will be thrilled to
know that chris pratt and bryce dallas
howard are reprising their roles as owen
grady and claire dearing thanks to the
jurassic world dominion trailer we also
know that isabella's sermon is returning
as maisie lockwood who as you probably
remember freed the dinosaurs at the end
of fallen kingdom the trio has been
living together since the events of the
last film with owen and claire becoming
maisie's guardians however these aren't
the only familiar faces returning for
dominion as the original jurassic park
trio of ian malcolm ellie sattler and
alan grant also prepared to reunite on
screen jeff goldblum all but confirmed
their return during an appearance on
watch what happens live i can't divulge
anything
but maybe maybe
in september 2019 trevorrow finally made
it official the director revealed that
goldblum laura dern and sam neil all had
key roles in the upcoming sequel
bringing the franchise full circle neil
dern and goldblum have all reprised
their iconic roles since starring in
1993's jurassic park together but this
core trio hasn't featured in the same
movie since appearing in the franchise
opener all those years ago goldblum's dr
ian malcolm popped up most recently
though his part in jurassic world fallen
kingdom was little more than a glorified
cameo speaking to empire trevorrow
explained why he chose to hold off on
throwing the legacy characters into the
mix properly until this moment the
filmmaker said we'd have had to come up
with a reason why ellie malcolm and
grant all went to the theme park on the
exact same day it broke down again the
next film allows the legacy characters
to be a part of the story in an organic
way co-writer emily carmichael and i
call it jurassic park 6 because it is
justice smith's franklin webb and
daniela pineda's zia rodriguez were both
introduced during jurassic world fallen
kingdom aiding the main stars in their
efforts to stop the movie's villainous
money-hungry mercenaries franklin a
jurassic world i.t technician turned
hacker and zia an ex-military paleo
veterinarian were on isla nublar
representing the dinosaur protection
group both had close shaves when the
dinosaurs they were there to protect
wreaked havoc on the island but they
escaped with their lives meaning a
return in the third jurassic world film
was always a possibility now their
comeback has been confirmed smith best
known for his lead role in live-action
pokemon movie detective pikachu and
pineda who appeared in netflix's cowboy
bebop series have both agreed to reprise
their jurassic world fallen kingdom
roles in the upcoming sequel it's a
chance for the two characters to develop
their relationship which smith claims is
most definitely platonic the actor told
slash film it's not romantic not in the
slightest we're not compatible
the way smith describes it franklin and
zia are more like brother and sister he
explained she kind of just picks on him
he tries to give it back to her and she
always ends up shutting him down that
just represents the bond that they have
they've worked together for so long
trying to save these dinosaurs after the
release of fallen kingdom pineda
revealed that a scene confirming that
zia was a lesbian had been cut from the
film hopefully jurassic world dominion
will take the time to develop this
aspect of her character
jake johnson put in a scene-stealing
performance as lowry crothers in
jurassic world so the news that he
wouldn't be returning for jurassic world
fallen kingdom was a blow for fans of
the easy-going control room worker i
understand people died it was terrible
but
that first park was legit
colin trevorrow told den of geek that
johnson who starred with aubry plaza and
the director's critically acclaimed
sci-fi rom-com safety not guaranteed
didn't show up in the first jurassic
world sequel because there wasn't a
quote genuine organic way to make it not
seem like he's just in it because he was
a great character in a previous film
now that the dinosaurs are out however
there's an opportunity to bring
characters that weren't dumb enough to
return to isla nublar in the second film
back into the story johnson will reprise
his role in jurassic world dominion and
he isn't the only returning cast member
from the first film french actor omar c
best known for international crossover
hit the untouchables has also signed up
for the threequel the european star
played raptor handler barry sembena in
jurassic world a friend and colleague of
chris pratt's owen grady see posted to
instagram and here we go again
it's safe to say that the jurassic world
dominion cast is stacked however that's
not stopped director colin trevaro from
adding several fresh faces to the film
too in 2019 deadline confirmed that
black box star mamadou atti had joined
the franchise and will take on the role
of bio-sin employee ramsay cole the
following day the outlet reported that
dewanda wise has also joined the cast of
dominion as pilot kayla watts wise spoke
to empire about her upcoming role
revealing a couple of details about her
character kayla she says is fresh out of
the air force and her main thing is
flying cargo mostly dinosaur stuff
thanks to the trailer we also know that
wise's character gets up close and
personal with a few dinosaurs during the
film but never fear because she's
working alongside chris pratt's owen
grady jurassic world dominion marks
irish musician and actor elva trill's
first international movie role not only
is this her biggest role to date but the
actor admitted to the irish independent
that joining the franchise was a dream
role for her since she was a huge fan of
jurassic park as a child trill is set to
play charlotte lockwood not much is
known about the character but it is
possible she's somehow appearing as the
daughter of benjamin lockwood who is
maisie's genetic template
the last installment of the jurassic
world franchise left viewers with scenes
of dinosaurs roaming around north
america after maisie lockwood freed them
arguing that they had as much a right to
live as she did now there's no going
back dominion picks up after the events
of fallen kingdom as the dinosaurs have
essentially taken over the world as dr
ian malcolm puts it in these three
equals first trailer humans are now
racing towards the extinction of our
species
we not only lack dominion over nature
we're subordinate to it
colin trevorrow revealed to collider
that the plot of jurassic world dominion
doesn't follow a traditional movie
structure instead the film follows two
parallel tracks on one side you have
owen claire and maisie and on the other
side you have ellie ian and alan trevaro
said we're telling two parallel stories
that are just driving closer and closer
together and you start to understand how
they're going to intersect and then they
do the film's second trailer revealed a
few details about what's going to be
happening in owen claire and maisie's
side of the story it begins by reuniting
owen and blue and the revelation that
the velociraptor had a baby however
moments later the baby is kidnapped owen
vows to get her back but based on past
experience we know it's not going to be
an easy mission meanwhile the original
trio are racing against the clock to
stop an ecological disaster
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
so now we have a bit more insight into
what happens in jurassic world dominion
the big question is when does it happen
in an interview with mtv news chris
pratt let slip that the film would
follow the events of jurassic world
fallen kingdom but implied that a
significant amount of time would have
passed since there was a three-year gap
between the events of jurassic world in
2015 and fallen kingdom in 2018
speculation was rife that dominion would
also follow this pattern and be set in
2021 this made sense given the film's
intended 2021 release date however since
it was pushed back a year that turned
out not to be the case speaking to
collider director colin trevaro
confirmed that it's set in real time and
because the release date was pushed back
the film is now presumably said in 2022
this time jump is important both in
terms of how far the dinosaurs have
spread and integrated themselves into
the wider world but also in terms of the
appearance of the cast macy lockwood was
a child of nine years old in fallen
kingdom but when dominion picks up she's
a teenager
there's one last addition to the slew of
new faces in jurassic world dominion and
it's quite a significant one in june
2020 collider announced that campbell
scott had joined the cast the amazing
spider-man actor will play lewis dodson
a nearly forgotten character from the
first jurassic park colin trevorrow held
nothing back when he spoke to
entertainment weekly about the character
revealing exactly what viewers could
expect from dodson he revealed he is the
main villain throughout both of
creighton's novels and i think what
campbell's done with the character is
just amazing i can't wait for people to
see it however there's one other villain
in the jurassic world franchise who's
still unaccounted for bd wong's
character dr henry wu was tipped to be
the film's big bad given his past track
record if you've forgotten he's
responsible for bringing the dinosaurs
back to life however he may have had a
change of heart in the movie's second
trailer wu can be seen speaking to
maisie lockwood and he appears a little
contrite
we made a terrible mistake
now that his genetic experiments have
resulted in dinosaurs walking the earth
for real this time perhaps he's changed
sides this time around
every new jurassic movie is an
opportunity to introduce some previously
unseen species of dinosaur and jurassic
world's dominion is no different colin
trevaro has been overseeing the
selection process since coming aboard
for 2015's jurassic world but he's had a
little help from his colleagues he told
jurassic outpost in 2018 i've been lucky
enough to be able to choose the
dinosaurs but derek connolly and j.a
biona and now emily carmichael will have
each made contributions when it's all
said and done it's just a bunch of kids
sitting on the floor with their toys the
filmmaker clearly relishes flicking
through his dino rolodex and
hand-picking the perfect dinosaur for
each specific scene but it's not all fun
and games he continued it's the best
part of my job but also the hardest you
have to keep some great ones in the tank
trevarro explained that he liked the
look of both the carnotaurus and the
baryonyx when he was putting the pieces
of jurassic world together but he didn't
want to see them reduced to background
dinosaurs as he put it they deserve an
entrance so he put them on the park map
but held the reveal for the second film
which dinosaurs has trevoro been holding
back for jurassic world dominion that
would be the giganotosaurus this is a
scientifically accurate dino from the
cretaceous period that's set to wreak
havoc on the world's human population
trevaro explained to empire i wanted
something that felt like the joker it
just wants to watch the world burn see
i'm not a monster
colin trevaro clearly wasn't the right
fit for star wars after all the director
was fired from episode 9 the rise of
skywalker over creative differences
despite having dedicated two years of
his life to the project i don't blame
people for their mistakes
but i do ask that they pay for them
but when it comes to the jurassic
franchise he's now the go-to guy he only
had the indie hit safety not guaranteed
to his name when he was chosen to helm
jurassic world but trevor apparently
handled the big budget blockbuster like
a seasoned pro impressing the man behind
the movie that started it all during his
entertainment weekly interview travarro
revealed that steven spielberg
personally asked him to helm the third
jurassic world film an offer that he
simply couldn't refuse steven spielberg
asked me to direct and when he asks you
what can i tell you man in all honesty
over my past few years i've grown to
love and cherish the value of the gift
that i've been given with this franchise
interestingly trevorrow only came aboard
the franchise after j.a biona turned
down the chance to direct jurassic world
while biona leader agreed to take the
reigns for fallen kingdom spielberg
apparently wanted trevarro back in the
hot seat for the all-important trilogy
capper
fourteen years passed between jurassic
park 3 and jurassic world though that
long gap wasn't down to a lack of trying
numerous sequels were reportedly floated
during that period the one that got
closest to getting greenlit came by way
of screenwriter john sales jurassic park
4 never got off the ground but what's
interesting is that a lot of sales ideas
ended up being used in jurassic world
and jurassic world fallen kingdom the
star of sales story was an unemployed
mercenary named nick harris who seems
very much like the blueprint for chris
pratt's ex-navy man owen grady most
notably it was sales who came up with
the idea of shady types attempting to
train dinosaurs as weapons the
overarching theme of the jurassic world
trilogy if this unused screenplay
influenced the two recent movies does it
also contain clues as to where jurassic
world dominion is heading according to
den of geek sales draft touches on the
idea of an america plagued by rogue
dinosaurs with the united states facing
its biggest ever threat a corporate
stooge spots a business opportunity we
know that some of the black market
bidders from jurassic world fallen
kingdom escaped the ill-fated auction
with their dinosaur specimens who will
the u.s government turn to when all
seems lost if this jurassic world 3
theory holds true humans will fight
dinosaurs with their own dinosaurs in an
effort to stave off extinction if i
don't make it back
remember
you're the one who made me come
in september 2019 a short film directed
by colin trevaro and written by
trevorrow and emily carmichael dropped
on the official jurassic world youtube
channel the eight-minute jurassic world
dominion prelude confirms that the movie
will indeed take place in an america
inhabited by rogue dinosaurs battle at
big rock features a family on a camping
trip in big rock a national park 20
miles from lockwood manor the mansion
that the dinosaurs escaped from at the
end of jurassic world fallen kingdom the
family's bonding time is interrupted
when a triceratops and its babies show
up and start digging through their food
they watch from the safety of their
trailer though the trailer doesn't offer
much protection when a hungry allosaurus
arrives on the scene after being fought
off by the parents of the little
triceratops the carnivore notices the
tasty looking humans and attacks
fortunately a fellow camper brought a
crossbow along and the daughter is a
pretty good shot the family escapes with
their lives but the implications are
clear woodland areas are no longer safe
for humans
how do they get all the way up here
they look great there was one in the
woods near my school
the shorts credits suggest that these
attacks are going to be commonplace by
the time we catch up with the gang in
jurassic world dominion
we know that dinosaurs will be lurking
in the wilderness thanks to the short
film but will these ancient animals be
terrorizing our cities too according to
travarro this won't be the case speaking
to fansite jurassic outpost the director
and co-writer of the upcoming prequel
said that there's no motivation for that
kind of behavior they can't organize
right now we've got lethal predators in
wild areas surrounding cities all over
the world they don't go pack hunting for
humans in urban areas the world i get
excited about is the one where it's
possible that a dinosaur might run out
in front of your car on a foggy back
road or invade your campground looking
for food this will be music to the ears
of those who were starting to get
worried about jurassic world dominion
becoming a cgi heavy disaster movie the
idea of raptors running rampant and
times square or a tyrannosaurus tearing
down hollywood boulevard might sound
cool in theory but that's not what this
franchise is about thankfully trevorrow
is well aware of this the director wants
to create a world where dinosaur
interaction is unlikely but possible the
same way we watch out for bears or
sharks we hunt animals we traffic them
we herd them we breed them we invade
their territory and pay the price but we
don't go to war with them
while they're obviously works of fiction
the jurassic movies have informed our
understanding of dinosaurs in a number
of ways particularly their appearance
the movies have always played into the
old idea of dinosaurs as giant scaly
beasts that didn't seem like much of a
problem when jurassic park premiered in
1993 but in recent years it has become
evident that they weren't actually as
reptile-like as we like to think fossils
unearthed in china have revealed that
dinosaurs belonging to the raptor family
were actually covered in feathers rather
than scales and in 2014 a discovery in
serbia appeared to confirm that all
dinosaurs shared this trade what does
this mean for the future of the jurassic
franchise when jurassic outpost raised
the feather question with colin
trevorrow the director said that he
would not alter the appearance of
dinosaurs we've already seen in the
previous movies those are established
characters to me they were made with
reptilian dna bridging the gaps in the
genome and they have their own identity
however he also added that now we're
headed into a world in which the ability
to clone a dinosaur is no longer
exclusive to dr henry wu that leads to
innovation and new opportunities for us
to introduce species that represent the
full spectrum of our knowledge
when colin trevorrow sat down with
empire to discuss the battle at big rock
short film in september 2019 the
director revealed some interesting
information about the animatronics that
were currently being created for the
upcoming sequel it had previously been
reported that oscar-winning creature and
special makeup effects supervisor neil
scanlon would be returning to ply his
trade on the follow-up but that won't be
the case scanlan perhaps best known for
his work on the star wars sequel trilogy
and spin-offs has chosen to pursue other
projects scanlan has been replaced by
john nolan who did some pretty amazing
work on the dark crystal age of
resistance in an appearance on the
empire film podcast trevaro said if any
of you have seen the dark crystal on
netflix john nolan who did all of the
animatronics for the dark crystal is
doing the animatronics on jurassic world
3. he's really innovating in a really
exciting way
jurassic world and a large part of its
sequel fallen kingdom were set on the
fictional isla nublar a remote island
off the coast of costa rica so most of
this filming took place in hawaii the
latter half of fallen kingdom is set in
north california but was filmed in the
uk both on location in berkshire and
hampshire and at pinewood studios the
cast and crew ventured further afield to
film the third installment of the
jurassic world franchise which is a big
globe-hopping adventure as colin trevaro
told collider however because of these
global locations the movie was deeply
affected by the pandemic lockdown once
production could resume filming began
again at pinewood studios but also took
place in new exciting locations like
malta and british columbia this globe
trotting is not just a picturesque plot
device either it shows just how far
across the world these dinosaurs have
spread dominion has a different tone
than the past jurassic world movies but
trevaro is excited for fans to see it
it's got a little bit of born and bond
and a bit of a spy movie thrown into it
too spy movie science thriller with
dinosaurs
in september 2020 jurassic world camp
cretaceous premiered on netflix the
dinos spin-off series follows six teens
as they attend an adventure camp on isla
nublar however their trip is quickly
interrupted when the dinosaurs escape
their habitats and the campers must try
to find a way off the island alive
jurassic world dominion director colin
trevaro co-wrote the show which is still
part of the jurassic franchise but aimed
at younger audiences he stressed to
entertainment weekly that camp
cretaceous is its own story however
thanks to travarro's involvement the
series does share a similar tone to the
upcoming film as we take the jurassic
franchise into a new place where it's
about humans and dinosaurs sharing the
planet as we do with animals it gives us
an opportunity to make more character
stories with people you know and love
and care about that's really our same
exercise on the show although he wants
to acknowledge the films and series
separately trevorrow told the outlet
that it felt important to him to
acknowledge camp cretaceous in the films
too so there will definitely be some
tie-ins he clarified exactly what fans
could expect when speaking to collider
what may be coming in the future of camp
cretaceous will tie in a bit more
directly to something in dominion
jurassic world was always billed as a
trilogy meant to continue the story of
jurassic park but for a new generation
however with its financial success it
makes sense that universal pictures
might want to extend the franchise
further back for more huh
however it appears the cast and crew are
quite divided on whether there is a
future for the jurassic film franchise
or not actor chris pratt seems ready to
put the dinosaur franchise to bed after
dominion a film which he said feels like
the end on the ellen degeneres show
director colin trevaro issued a similar
sentiment to collider saying for the
last three movies i've done with it what
i thought was a cool way to move it
forward and to respect what steven and
what michael crichton have created
although he added he's only a custodian
of the jurassic franchise which is much
bigger than him and he couldn't speak to
its future it sounds like he might be
ready to call it a day jurassic world
producer frank marshall takes a
different view however he told collider
quote it's a new era what that could
mean for the future of the franchise is
unclear but what we do know is that
viewers can expect dominion to bring the
main jurassic world story lines to a
close check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies and tv shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]